air pollution consists of chemicals or
particles in the atmosphere that pose
serious health and environmental threats
but what causes air pollution and what
does it mean for our planet some air
pollution comes from natural sources
like volcanic eruptions wildfires or
allergens but most air pollution results
from human activities such as energy use
and agriculture there are different
types of human-made air pollution when
we burn fossil fuels to produce energy
they release greenhouse gases into the
air these emissions such as carbon
dioxide methane nitrous oxide and
fluorinated gases trap heat from the Sun
in Earth's atmosphere leading to a rise
in global temperatures this creates a
cycle where air pollution contributes to
climate change and climate change
creates higher temperatures in turn
higher temperatures intensify some types
of air pollution for example climate
change increases smog because it forms
in the presence of high heat and
increased levels of ultraviolet
radiation more frequent extreme weather
such as flooding contributes to damp
conditions and therefore to arise and
mold warmer weather also leads to longer
pollen seasons and therefore more pollen
production smog is a type of air
pollution that reduces visibility and
has serious health effects
smog can be divided into two categories
sulphurous and photochemical sulfurous
smog is made up of chemical compounds
called sulfur oxides it occurs when
burning sulfur bearing fossil fuels such
as coal photochemical smog also called
ground-level ozone is a result of the
reaction between sunlight nitrogen
oxides and volatile organic compounds
nitrogen oxides come from car exhaust
coal power plants and factory emissions
volatile organic compounds are released
from gasoline paints and many cleaning
solvents smog not only creates a brown
haze that reduces visibility but also
harms plants irritates the eyes and
causes respiratory distress another
category of air pollution is toxic
pollutants these are chemicals such as
mercury lead dioxins and benzene that
are released during gas or coal
combustion waste incineration or burning
of gasoline in addition to adverse
environmental effects toxic air
pollution can cause serious health
problems such as cancer reproductive
complications and birth defects
[Music]
while air pollution has many
consequences for our planet there are
solutions we can limit toxic pollutants
smog and greenhouse gases by decreasing
the use of fossil fuels such as in
transportation manufacturing and
electricity generation reducing air
pollution not only contributes to a
cleaner environment and better human
health but can also slow the rate of
global warming
[Music]